[Music]
critique is so limiting and emotionally
draining I hope you find something to
explain what's happening which one's
better one would do better worse no
different no different I am quite
curious to know II think I think sober
hasn't been good for him
Pierce was in the full bloom of
alcoholism ear exactly never should have
quit drinking no originality no courage
I mean I can't save you
what did these mesmeric and you just
took them family or friends I can make
you rich really demand has people ready
to kill I mean as an artist and
eventually Diesel's no records we have
everyone the artist used blood to create
the reddish block
you ever notice anything about this
picture look at it long enough a moose
as I research these I'm starting to
think there's been discussed for the
world of money you spent decades in
psychiatric hospital for the criminally
insane
some sort of power
some spirits
it's connected to his art
something truly goddamn strange is going
on this is a slaughterhouse are you
aware of the desaster dollars aren't be
destroyed
[Music]
[Applause]
get rid of it
I can't save you
[Music]
[Music]
people thought she was part of exhibit
we're trending on Instagram it's a major
hit
[Music]
you